You're listening to radio
lab radio from WNYCC
and NPR one when you die,
we can all agree on
this. Something changes.
You get the feeling that something
that was there isn't there or leaves.
But what leave one, two, three. Can
you hear me? We talked to a biologist,
a at Princeton University, Lee silver,
who told us a story about a guy back
in 1907 who did a very interesting
experiment. His name was Duncan
MacDougall. I don't know.
I don't remember exactly who he was.
Was he was he was a doctor. A doctor.
A physician, yes. And what's his story?
He wanted to prove that I'm
the sole exited the body after.
Yeah.
He thought the sole had a certain amount
of weight, that it was a substance.
And so what he did was he had these people
who were dying from tuberculosis and
he, he, they were lying on
beds on this gigantic scale.
He literally put people almost
dying onto a under a scale. Yes.
So imagine how a patient on one side
of the scale and on the other side are
weights and they're,
they're in perfect balance.
And then at the moment of
death, right at the last breath,
he tried to determine whether
or not the scale changed.
So did they lose weight when they
died? That was the question. Right.
And he claimed that on
average they lost 21 grams.
The instant they died. Oh, did,
did it as he described the moment that
suddenly the scales shift one way or the
other? Yeah, the moment, I mean,
death was easy in those days because
you stopped breathing. You were dead.
I mean, there were, there weren't you,
they weren't hooked into brain scans.
Right. So it's the, the last
breath. Oh, that's man. Yes. Um,
and the New York Times headline was,
so has weight physician thinks, right.
Great headline. Right? And this is
the beginning of the 20th century.
We're not talking about
medieval times to remember that.
What did he conclude from
this soul has weight. Okay.
I seen a soul.
It was there when he was alive and it
flew off and it weighs 21 grams. Yes.
Now there was one person whose
weight didn't change immediately.
It changed a minute later.
And so his hypothesis was that this was
a very kind of dumb guy and the soul
was, didn't realize it was free. And
so it took a minute after the death,
before the soul realized it was
freeing. It flew out out of the body.
So at true idiot would be
hanging out like your for five
now. This was very
serious. Of course. Yeah.
How would you explain what he saw
or thought he saw the 21 grams?
I'm still stuck on that.
I mean 21 grams. It's,
it's statistically insignificant.
You mean three quarters of an ounce
compared to the weight of a body is a
minuscule amount.
Particularly he says Lee,
when you consider how crude
the scales were at the time,
almost anything could have swayed
them. I'll breeze the pressure.
Anything really, uh, today, hey,
we'd be laughed out of the academy.
You ever seen someone die or ever seen
a dead person? I've seen dead people.
I mean, I've seen dead bodies.
[inaudible] I do. Do you, I mean, I,
I just want my mom just before she
died and just after she died. Yes.
And I thought to myself, um,
there's a real difference here. It's,
it's beyond power or it's a,
it's a very noticeable
deep absence of something.
And it does make you think that something,
I'll use the word carefully.
Vital has gone away. Suddenly
we have to be very careful about the
words. I mean, something has gone away.
The brain has ceased to function and
therefore I would say there is no person.
It's still the unanswered question is
what really happens in that moment when a
person is suddenly
gone
to the other side, the other side,
those of us with the benefit of being
alive cannot help but ask this question.
It's like a curse. We want to know,
but obviously it's not something you can
know because this will just always be
one of those domains. What are the tools
of science just can't be used. Alas.
But then there are those folks like
neuroscientist, David Eagleman who say,
screw it. We're going to ask.
We're going to wonder cause
that's just what we do.
When you walk to the end
of the pier of science,
you look out and you've
got everything beyond that.
You've got the whole ocean of what we
don't know past the end of the pier.
What a scientist does is sort of leap
out onto different islands and just try
things out. I'm Jab, I'm Rod and I'm
Robert Belviq. Today on radio lab,
we're going to do what David Eagleman
suggests. We're just going to hop around.
This is unusual for us, but what the heck?
We're going to look at
different aspects of, yeah,
and the other side in no particular
order, but here's what we can tell you.
We're going to make 11
stops, 11 meditations,
shall we call them on various questions
relating to death and dying and what
happens after
won't be depressing. No, you just
heard the first one, so has wait.
Physician thinks. Here's our second
[inaudible] comes to us from a,
the guy you just heard David Eagleman
who is a neuroscientist but wrote a book
called some. Yeah. Which is very
not neurosciencey at all. Truth is,
I haven't talked about this book with
any of my science colleagues. Why not?
I have reasons why,
but I'm not sure I want
to say them on the radio. In any case,
the book consists of 40 different
versions of the afterlife and here's one,
it's called metamorphosis written by
David Eagleman and read by Jeffrey Tambor,
the Ecuador, right? There
are three depths. Now,
the first is when the body
ceases to function of course,
and the second is when the
body is consigned or you know,
put in the grave.
The third is that moment sometime in
the future when your name is spoken,
who the last time
[inaudible] [inaudible].
So
you wait in this lobby
until the third death
and there are long tables
with coffee and tea cookies.
You can help yourself in there.
There are people here from all around
the world and with a little effort,
you can strike up some
convivial smalltalk.
Just be aware that your conversation
could be interrupted at any moment by a
while. We call them the Kohler
Thompson parents,
and what they do is they
broadcast your new friend's name
to indicate that they will never again
be another remembrance of him by anyone
on the earth.
[inaudible]
your friend's slumps saddened. Even
though the callers, they tell him, kindly,
look, you're, you're, you're
off to a better place.
[inaudible]
the thing is,
no one knows where that better place is
or what it offers because no one exiting
through that door is returned to tell us
[inaudible]
and tragically,
many people leave just as their loved
ones arrived since the loved ones,
we're the only ones doing the remembering
and we all wag our heads at that
typical timing. Now,
not everyone is sad when their callers
shout out their next list of names.
On the contrary, some people
bank and they, they plead to,
these are generally the guys
who've been here a long time.
Yeah, too long.
We take that farmer over there who
drowned in a small river 200 years ago.
I get this,
his farm is the side of a small college
now and the tour guides each week tell
his story. So he, he's, he's stuck.
He's, he's miserable. The
more his story is told,
the more the details drift.
He's utterly alienated from his name
and it's no longer identical with him,
but it continues to bind and
that cheerless woman across
the way is praised as a
saint even though the roads in her
heart believed me were complicated.
And I guess that is the curse of this room
because since we live in the
heads of those who remember us,
we lose control of our lives
and become who they want us.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
what gave you the idea for that
story? This actually, I should say,
came out of my work as a neuroscientist
because what happens in the brain is you
make models of other people
when you think, well,
what would my friends such and such
say, or what would my wife say?
You're actually running a little
simulation of that person in your head.
Well,
what happens when somebody dies is that
they exist only in the scattered heads
around the globe of people who knew them.
They exist in some way as these
algorithms that continue to run,
but through time you, your
model of somebody might drift.
[inaudible] are we ready?
[inaudible] a number three. I'm going
to change up the question a bit.
When am I dead?
How do you decide if
somebody is alive or dead?
If you take it as your starting
point? King Lear Shakespeare,
when Cordelia, his daughter died
[inaudible] takes out
a mirror looking glass,
puts it right under her nose to
see if there is some breadth there.
Is that that breath well missed or
staying the CT set of fitness feather.
Just the same thing.
And that is how he decides
if she's on or off.
Yes, and it's really one of the most
beautiful scenes in Shakespeare.
That's Gary Greenberg. He wrote
a book called the noble lie.
When it's done right, it's
impossible not to weep.
She has gone farther at that scene
and the intimacy of that moment.
But if you fast forward a few
hundred years, things change.
All right? It's 18, 16.
There's a fat lady in a hospital where
in France and in walks a guy by the,
what was his name? Do you
have few Cleon sheath? Yeah.
Mac lantack. Yeah, he's a doctor.
He's a dusk fellow. Okay. Yes.
And he is called in to consult with, uh,
a patient who is obese, obese, and
ill. He says to this lady, please,
may I see your wrist. So
said, I can feel your pulse.
But this woman had so much flesh on
her that the only way he could imagine
to do it was to put his ear on her chest,
which would have been in decent.
Mm. So came up with an idea.
He fabricated quite quickly.
A device rolled up paper really
and fashioned it into a tube,
put one into the tube on the woman's
chest and his year on the other end. Oh,
how very decent of him. So he
doesn't have to touch her flesh.
He doesn't have to even
really look at her chest.
His head is actually turned
away from the patient.
And so what we've got here in 1816
is the world's first stethoscope.
And a very unintimidating increasingly
precise and technological approach to
defining death, which now is all
about the heart. Up until then,
a death was heart death. People are
dead when their heart stops speeding.
But if you fast forward again,
things take another term like
just imagine thought experiment.
If King Lear had been
written not in 1604 but 1968
[inaudible]
LBJ administration. Okay.
Cordelia with [inaudible]
[inaudible]
there would be distraught but instead
of doing the mirror thing again,
he would call a doctor who would rush
her to the hospital, shock her heart,
resuscitate her, hook her up to
a ventilator and a feeding tube.
And there she would be alive again.
Sort of. I mean technically, yes, she'd
be alive cause her heart would be,
but the core Delia that he knew
his daughter would be gone.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Mama
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and this was the problem in 1968
with all this new technology,
ICU units were filling up with these
purgatorial Cordelia's who floated
somewhere in a comatose
state between life and death.
You could minister to these
people, you could feed them,
you could clear their infections. But you
could not restore their consciousness.
What are you going to do with
these people? In walks a physician,
a very prominent American
physician named Henry Beecher,
and he decided that the time he'd
come to acknowledge the obvious,
which to him was these people
weren't just dying, they were dead.
He convened a committee at Harvard and
he simply moved the line that divides
life from death back a little bit toward
what most people would consider life.
And so you get in that moment, the concept
of brain death person is really dead.
We really did not, when
they stopped breathing,
not when their heart stops beating,
but when their brain winks out,
that now is when a person
really dies. Exactly.
Totally invented concept, but it stuck.
One way to argue it that the brain was
considered to be sort of the Maestro,
the coordinating Oregon that made all
of the rest of the body work and without
it, the center no longer
holds and things fall apart.
And nowadays most people go with
this brain dead definition of death,
but where it gets weird is
it? There are some [inaudible]
just a few. For instance,
some sex of Orthodox Judaism will
say that if the heart is beating,
the lungs are still filling with Aaron.
If the lungs are still feeling
like they're still a soul,
the spirit of God is in you and you
certainly can't be said to be dead. Well,
I'll give you another
example. That's John Troyer,
associate of death and dying practices
at the University of bath. For example,
Italy, they use the brain death criteria.
The Vatican, however its own city,
state within the country
of Italy does not.
The Vatican goes only by heart death.
So technically according to John,
it's possible that if I were brain-dead
in Italy and doctor wanted to pull my
plug but my family didn't,
they could just wheel me down the
street into the Vatican and I'd be alive
again.
Yeah, I mean you'd need a really
long extension cord probably.
Cause of course these are all,
I mean you'd be on machines
and devices that require power.
So I mean it would be a laborious
process to say the least. Nonetheless,
the real question here, the deeper one,
is it, when do you die?
Is it brain versus heart?
It's when are you gone?
Like when is a father a son, a daughter
really gone to us and who gets to
decide that? And that's there in lies.
The rub dead to family can be very
different than dead to an institution that
might be caring for that body.
You know that that scene of leader
with the mirror is in the feathers.
It's not a medical diagnosis.
It's a diagnosis about
love and lungs. Ooh,
stay a little.
And number four, tennis. Anyone.
Let me tell you about a woman.
She was the victim of a
road traffic accident,
but that's Dr Adrian Owen.
He's a neuroscientist at
the University of Cambridge.
And he told me about this patient. He had
a patient who's in her thirties and
she came to us after five months in a
vegetative state following
a blow to her head.
So for five months she'd
been lying in the hospital,
couldn't talk or couldn't
move. He could breathe,
but no evidence of any awareness would
shine light in her eyes.
She wouldn't have the normal response
in the fact that woman was gone.
That's right.
But in spite of the fact that she
was giving the world nothing back,
Dr. Owen wondered, would it just be
possible that there was somebody in there
[inaudible]
so we tried a new kind of
approach with her. Yeah.
Because they had a new and sophisticated
tool that previous scientists,
I never had any rain scanner. Yeah.
This is a stethoscope for the brain.
Dr. Owens stood by her bedside
and said, tell you what,
in a few minutes we're going to take
you to a machine. You chat with her.
You say, hey,
that's exactly how it's
done. Yes, it sounds, um,
a little bit bizarre because of course
you don't get any responses back from
these patients. You don't
even know whether they can
hear you, but we, you know,
we might instructions very clear. Yeah.
And he says, now when we
put you in the machine,
there's going to be a click and I'm
going to say into your ear, please begin
to imagine playing a
vigorous game of tennis.
What
we said,
imagine that you're standing there at
the baseline Wimbledon carrying out the
movements.
Dennis. See because here's the thing,
we now know enough about brains to know
that if you are imagining tennis, yeah.
Well, produce activity
in your motor cortex.
Very similar to the activity that you
would see if you could scan somebody when
they were actually
playing a game of tennis.
And this is true of all healthy people.
That's right. Oh, it's the same pattern.
Yeah.
It lights up very reliably.
Okay, so he taped puts this patient into
a brain scan and he rolls her into the
machine.
When we say right, play tennis, now relax,
play tennis. Now relax.
And you said this woman's been
vacant for five months. Yeah,
I get to see this seems quite literally
a shot or a forehand in the dark.
This was his first patient. Really?
He does this. He says, play,
stop, play, stop.
She hadn't spoken or showing any sense
of awareness or any interior life at all
for months and months
and months and months and
tennis on the screen.
Here's a tennis game.
[inaudible]
what we saw is exactly what
we see in healthy volunteers.
No premotor cortex is turning on and
turning off. When we asked her to relax,
turning on
when we asked her to do the task
and it would stop when
we asked her to relax.
So she's in there, she's in there. Oh,
were you amazed or were you,
uh, expected? What will you,
what happened to you?
Um, well, yeah, I mean, it, it was,
it was pretty exciting.
I'm going to have to say the fact that
it was the first person who tried it in
with was perhaps the biggest surprise.
And we've scanned about 20 patients since
then doing the same thing. And we've,
we've seen three so far who,
uh, showed clear signs of, uh,
of being aware.
See, that's the thing that sort
of frightens me about you've done,
it seems to me you've discovered that
there may have been and there may be lots
of people in this world who are somehow
aware but who are invisible to the rest
of us,
whom we could in effect
murder it by mistake.
Yeah. Well, that's obviously
very, um, loaded question.
Uh, I mean I think we, you know,
we have to face the side that historically
we haven't always had the tools that
we have today that can help us
to make a complex decisions.
But we're very early stages
of this and they're awesome.
Some also very technical reasons why
one needs to be extremely cautious about
drawing conclusions from
this. For example, you know,
we could tell with this patient that
she was aware and what we can't do is to
conclude that the rest of
them were definitely unaware.
[inaudible]
imagine if you were stone deaf and you
appear to be in a vegetative state.
Now in that situation,
we wouldn't necessarily know that
you were stone deaf because you've,
you've had a major brain injury and
we can't talk to you and find out.
So we don't know that you're stone deaf.
We put you in the scan and we asked
you to imagine playing tennis,
but you can't even hear
the instructions. Actually,
that patient wouldn't
imagine playing tennis.
They wouldn't activate
their premotor cortex.
But it wouldn't be because they weren't
aware it would be because they were
deaf.
Oh dear.
So even though we can tell
when a patient is aware,
we can't tell when a patient
is unaware. And that's very,
very important distinction.
But if you can't really know
that someone is unaware,
and then you can't actually ever
really know if they're gone.